I've been at yahoo now for just over
nine months and basically the first part
of this has been about getting the right
people in place and really getting the
culture and the energy where we wanted
it to be you know it turns out there's a
lot of fantastic folks at Yahoo and
they've been you know they've been
sitting there with their ideas and
really wanting to run and I just think
that you know through various twists and
turns the recession various turn to the
top those things have gotten in the way
mm-hmm right my job as an executive is
to play defense well I'm let the team
play offense and we've been getting the
right team in place and really getting
the right product ideas in place and
getting the vibe and the energy of a
place where we want it to be so we can
really we can really run